عواقب وخيمه بانتظارنا نحن البشر ففي احدى
السنوات الخمس المقبله سترتفع حراره الارض
بنحو درجه ونصف درجه مئويه وستكون الاعلى
في تاريخ الكوكب منذ الثوره الصناعيه هذا
ما كشفه تقرير جديد للمنظمه العالميه
للارصاد الجويه التقرير كشف ايضا ان درجه
حراره القطب الشمالي سترتفع ثلاثه اضعاف
عن المتوسط العالمي ورجح ايضا ان يكون
هناك هطول اقل للامطار هذا العام في منطقه
الامازون وامريكا الوسطى واستراليا
واندونيسيا وكل ذلك قد يؤدي الى تداعيات
كارثيه ويرسل العالم الى منطقه مجهوله
وفقا لوصف المنظمه فهذه التداعيات قد تؤثر
مستقبلا في الصحه والامن الغذائي واداره
المياه والبيئه في المقابل يقول تقرير ان
هذا التغيير لن يكون دائما فمن المتوقع ان
تنخفض الحراره لاحقا
[موسيقى]